how are you both great fine
Danny blasted porn on the Bluetooth
speakers
literally melted from overuse would you
believe me now if my life is a mess my
husband kicked me out a few days ago
my daughter hates me
oh my God Mom threesome is a big leap
maybe you were a subconsciously worried
about our little threesome about what me
and you and Dad
how did I get so far from the person I
wanted to be
what would I tell my
my two-year-old self
stop worrying whether you're fat who
gives a
stop obsessing about your nose your nose
is perfect don't take your mom for
granted she won't be here forever Blair
Marie Pierce is an award-winning essay
writer and soon to be college graduate
with a 4.0
everything
best writers I know an advice column is
easy clicks okay take a look you should
be the one doing this I'm not giving
anybody advice
what would I tell my 22 year old self
someday you'll look back on that one
Christmas when your mother gave you a
mustard yellow coat don't hold it up and
say it's too puffy because your mother
will be dead by Spring and that coat
will be the last gift she ever gave you
I wish you weren't my mom
because that would be the last thing
that you would ever said to me you're
not the only one that could die tomorrow
so could I
thing to say to me
[Music]
much for you but you're not gonna get
any of it if you don't want it for
yourself
[Music]
to let go
why can't you make new friends like what
happened to Bethany Bethany had anal sex
on a greyhound going to Reno what yeah
why would she want to take a bus to Reno